みなさんこんにちは
私の名前は井戸が基準
大阪歯科大学の大学院生です
私の専門は高齢者歯科
高齢者の役に立つ治療を勉強し実際に治療を行っています
患者さんには
車いすが必要な方
うまくしゃべれない方
介護が必要な方がいらっしゃいます
皆さん
介護と聞いてどんなイメージがありますか
少し考えてみてください
3つ数えます
ターン
どんなイメージでしたか
わくわくするようなイメージ楽しいイメージ
興奮するようなイメージですか
では
ないですよね
2週間に
一度
この数字何の数字かわかりますか
今
日本では
週間に一度
介護殺人が起きています
介護を始めて事件を起こすまでの期間1年未満が26%
事件発生時の介護サービスの利用度75%
介護サービスを利用していないから事件を起こした
ではないんです
介護をしている人のアンケート調査では相手を手にかけたい
一緒に死にたいと思った人4人に1人でした
これらのデータから
介護て
すごく疲れる
私は思いました
介護は決して楽なものではありません
しかしそのイメージ協会てみせます
今日私がお話しするのは介護する方もされる方も楽しくなるようなアイディア
明るい介護です
私はこのアイディア実践してきています
そうすると思いがけない方向に笑顔の連鎖が広がっていったんです
そもそもこんなアイディアを考えたきっかけ
僕の祖父子です
僕の家族紹介します
父と母そして祖父母と一緒に暮らしています
これはお子が来ている時ですね
親戚がよく遊びに来る楽しい家族です
そそは82歳お口みてください
歯が1本もなくなりそういえばになってしまいました
祖父は93歳同じく総入れ歯になってしまい
目も見えなくなってしまいました
元気だった祖父母も
元気なのですが若いときと比べてすっかり体が弱ってしまいました
体が弱るとこんな時が荒れます
殴る怒鳴るいいです
もういきなりです
介護はするほうもされるほうも必死
これが介護です
私は毎日どうしたら祖父母が笑顔になってくれるか考えました
何も高齢者の方が理由もなしに暴力的なアプローチをするのではないのです
必ず理由があります
様々な理由のなかの一つ
寂しいという感情です
寂しいという感情は相手にしてほしいがために
時に暴力的なアプローチをとるのです
どうしたら祖父母が笑顔になってくれるのか
それは寂しくならないようにすればいいのです
そこで考えたのが僕のアイディア
明るい介護です
明るい介護のためのステップ1
とにかく会う
会う勇気を持ってください
喧嘩すでー気まずいときもあります
学校や仕事で余裕がなくて
自分会いたくない時もありますそれでも会う勇気を持ってください
短い時間でもいいんですとにかく会う
これからすべてが始まります
リップに
笑顔であいさつ
この画像を見てください名細めて口角を上げてめっちゃ可愛い
てっ
僕この写真を見て皆さんのように笑ってしまいました
笑顔って笑顔を巻き込んでイベント相手も笑顔になります
こんな笑顔きてあげてください
けどーこれでは不十分です
笑顔は生まれますが元気は生まれません
そこで
step 3
元気にするために何かする
皆さん熱意を持って真剣に取り組んだものを見せてあげてください
につい思って真剣に取り組んだものには相手を元気にする力があります
どんな鼻メガネでもいいんです
おばあちゃん花見はれやでー
いつか笑ますね
やっ
熱意を持って取り組んだものを向けるこれが大切です
このアイデアを考えた時に
思ったことがあります
何かする
自分で何ができるんやろう
考えました
そのヒントは日常生活にあったんです
紹介します
体が入りたい
祖母がいいます
そうだマッサージ
マッサージの勉強しました
マッサージの勉強するなら本場で
単位に留学しました
毎日マッサージの練習
もちろんタイ語何言ってるかわかりませんマッサージ法音符練習しました
そうすると
タイの厚労省から免許をいただきました
祖母が免許持ってるんですごく喜んでくれました
祖母の笑顔と免許まで手に入りました
やっぱ
食べにくい
ソースがいいます
そうだはに詳しくなろう
小さい時から食事終わればいれば笑
文字通り
はと向き合っていましたん
その結果
歯科医になりました
今では治療を通して祖父母だけではなく患者さんの笑顔にできるようになりました
患者さんから学ぶことってすごく多いんです
それをまとめて今学会で発表してます
そうすると全国の先生と交流ができて祖父母の土産話も増えます
帰ってくると祖父母が学会どうやったって聞いてくれます
全国で学会があるので話題が尽きることはありません
祖父母の笑顔がどんどんどんどん広がっていきました
驚かせて楽しませよ
そうだマジック
小さい時は定時なぶ大きくなるとマジックバーでマジックの練習
練習してその後にどうって見せてました
海外に行った時に練習したマジックを
そうするとみんな笑顔になったんです
言葉の壁を通り越えて笑顔になりました
オーストラリアでは日本語教授の助手というアルバイトをしていました
その時に子供たちにマジックをそうすると年齢の壁を飛び越えてみんな笑顔になったん
です
そうした活動していると
オーストラリアの新聞に載りました
入ってくるとなんで海外の新聞載ってるんで
マジック以上にを届かせることができました
よし
ある日
祖父が通っているデイサービスにアナウンサーがやってきました
朗読ボランティアです
アナウンサーが本読むと利用者の方も
そして職員の方もみんな色になりました
言葉の力ってすごい
そうだ楽しく話そう
そう思いました
そこで
アナウンス学校に行きました
絵本の読み聞かせ話し方勉強
そうすると
そのデイサービスでマジックショーすることになりました
動く緊張しました
もちろん最善てっ家にいるのは僕の祖父
マジックをする前からすごく笑顔デー
うちの孫がマジックすねーどんどんどんどんハードル上げていきます
すごく緊張したのでそうだ祖父母だけに見せようという感じで前でこう見てました
デフと会場を見渡しました
そうするとみんなが笑顔になってたんです
祖父母のためにしたことが
7ためになりました
今私は
歯磨き順としてボランティア活動しています
井戸が基準から
歯磨き順になったんです
これが磨き順です宜しくお願いします
う
ボランティア活動は速健康の話へフォンの読み聞かせ
マジックをしています
歯の話は
食べにくいから
健康の話は
体が痛いから
絵本の読み聞かせは楽しく話したいからマジックは驚かせて楽しましてあげたいから
祖父母を笑顔にできたんだから他の人の笑顔にできるそう思って活動しています
今私は挑戦していることがあります
祖父は
93歳
目が見えなくなり
テレビが見えなく娯楽はラジオです
私のマジックでは元気にすることができません
そこで考えたのが
聞いて楽しいマジックこれ挑戦中です
歯磨き順として活動していると
ラジオ出演させていただきました
そこで聴いて楽しいま実行しました
楽しいかどうかわかりません
ただ帰ってくると
聞いたで面白かったでって言って祖父は喜んでくれました
まずは成功です
それから一度にどうまた今月にもラジオ出演させていただくのでもしかしたら聴いて
くれた人が楽しんでくれたのかもしれません
祖父母のためにしていたことが
歯科医師になり患者さん a そして
ボランティア活動が
高齢者施術の方そしてラジオを聴いてくれた人とどんどんどんどん映画をが広がって
いきました
私はこのアイディアの力を知っています
そして誰かにやってほしいそして共有したいと思い
高齢者に対して考える勉強会
そういうを設立しました
for you では一人で勉強からみんなで勉強
みんなで勉強するとさまざまなアイディアが出ます
そしてアイディアで終わらせるのではなく活動として実践しています
個人としてではできない高齢者としての何か
私から広がった笑顔の連鎖そして for you から広がる笑顔の連鎖
さらなる笑顔の連鎖として広がっていきます
私には変えたい未来があります
これからどんどんどんどん高齢者が増えて
ドンドンドンドンドンドン介護問題が深刻になっていきます
介護と聞いて暗いだけの未来
そんな未来は嫌です
歯磨き順としてそして for you のメンバーとして戦っていきます
初めはこんな感じ白衣着て大きな歯ブラシさせて
4持ってただがむしゃらに頑張ってきただけです
今ではこれだけの笑顔が広がりました
てリックス大阪いうのテーマしずく
私から広がった笑顔の連鎖
あなたから広がる笑顔の連鎖
介護のイメージを明るいものに変える力になります
最後にみなさんこれだけ覚えてください
とにかく会う
笑顔であいさつ
元気にするために何かする
最後にみなさんに質問です
あなたは高齢者のために
何ができますか
ありがとうございます
[拍手]